having problems paying your utility
bills NV Energy the sponsors of this
next segment are here to help joining us
now to talk about their Flex Pay is
Antoine Tillman the vice president of
customer operations welcome back to the
show hey there how are you doing it's
always great to chat with you FlexPay
tell me more about it so FlexPay is a
program it's a prepaid program customers
actually pay when when they want to so
you'll basically kind of like a gas card
right you you have your vehicle you keep
gas in it if it gets low you fill it up
so Flex Pay similar to that it's a
prepaid program for CV energy your
paying as the month goes on versus the
traditional at the end of the month you
get your utility bill correct correct so
what you're doing is you're actually
seeing what you're using on a daily
basis and then you're keeping that based
on your consumption you can keep your
gas tank full okay someone's watching
right now how do they qualify this how
do they sign up for this so everybody's
qualified and your meter is the only
thing so if we have a meter that we can
remotely disconnect or connect that
qualifies you for that program there are
some other other exceptions to that but
what if you go to our website it'll show
you what what those are are you is there
a credit check involved or anyone just
could jump on there and sign up no the
best thing there is no credit check
matter of fact if you have a deposit you
can actually have that deposit reversed
and apply to your account while you set
up on FlexPay is there a deposit initial
deposit to start up your Flex Pay
someone's going to sign up do they have
to put fifty dollars like putting fifty
dollars in a tank to fill your car up
for the first time so there is that that
initial payment that you'll do and
that'll go to towards your gas tank okay
it's not like a deposit fee that's going
to your actual bill right it's going
right into your gas tank so it's not a
deposit that we're holding just in case
it's actually going towards your your um
account oh I like this you put 50 bucks
in and then your business is there a
minimum to start or whatever you can
afford you start off with there's no
minimum to start the fifty dollars is
the minimum to start that but once
you're once you go from there there's no
minimum depending on how you pay there
are minimums amount that you can pay but
from different areas you can actually
pay as if you only need two dollars you
could put two dollars on there this is
great yes you guys always give back to
Las Vegas and you're looking out for
your customers and that's what I love
about ND energy you really do you care
about this community yes yes and this
program has really designed if you fall
behind on your account the best thing
about this account is when you make a
payment let's say you you pay a dollar
yep
um and you owe us some money 20 of I'm
sorry 20 cents of that dollar goes
towards your rares and and then the
other 80 goes into your gas tank this is
great and it happens automatically so
you just relax just keep the gas tank
full and everything else to take care of
itself I gotta wrap it up real quick
someone's going leaving for the holidays
leaving town for like a week what should
they leave their thermostat at when it
comes to their heater so again if your
your comfort zone is about 68 to 70 is
what we recommended in the winter time
so dropping that down to about 64 is a
safe bet you could drop it down later
depending on the envelope of your home
perfect awesome thank you so much
Antoine we appreciate it and thank you
to Envy energy for sponsoring this
segment for more information visit
nbenergy.com forward slash Flex Pay
we'll be right back